mais de quoi va-t-on parler aujourd'hui
vous le savez vous avez cliqué sur le
lien je peux pas vous faire de petites
blagues on vous en deviner on va parler
de ce smartphone la smart femme à qui
vient tout juste d'être annoncé en
france c'est leur il me 7
irie demi c'est une marque qui a été
créée en 2018 une marque est très
récente et qui est arrivé en france en
2020 avec plein de smartphones
extrêmement intéressant j'en ai déjà
beaucoup parlé de remy d'ailleurs merci
rémi de sponsoriser cette vidéo remy ma
demande aujourd'hui vous parler du ring
17e' tout nouveau produit situé dans
l'entrée de gamme
je sais pas si vous connaissez la gamme
16h30 alors il me 7 pro vous avez le
remy 7 et vous retrouver ce rythme me
7,6 qui vous propose une très grosse
batterie avec une très belle autonomie
mais sans concessions au niveau de
l'expérience de gaming
je vais donc vous présenter ce
smartphone aujourd'hui savoir ce qu'il a
sous le capot s'il est fait pour vous
s'il peut vous intéresser
parce qu'on est quand même sur un
smartphone qui coûte au moins de 200
euros
je vous met le prix en bas dans la
description parce que moment où je fais
cette vidéo j'ai smartphones sous
embargo c'est à dire que ce smartphone
est avec moi depuis quelques jours je
teste mais je n'ai pas le droit de le
montrer il est caché et je n'ai pas le
prix tout de suite je sais juste qu'il a
moins de 100 euros le prix est en bas
dans la description votre ennemi c'est y
ait caché normalement dans cette boîte
les boîtes jaunes les fameuses boîtes
jaunes deux heures et demie ça je vous
les ai déjà déjà montré on a quelques
uns font et on le voit tout de suite ici
la grosse batterie de 6000 millions
perreur le processeur la triple caméra
avec une caméra de 48 mégapixels et la
recharge rapide 18 watts bon je vous
passe un petit peu ça pour vous montrer
ce qui nous intéresse à savoir le
smartphone alors je pas si vous le voyez
il ya un truc est très sympa c'est que
ça vous fait un design en v on est un
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
déverrouille très rapidement ça c'est
plutôt agréable
il existe en deux couleurs ici c'est le
bleu victorieux avec le v
de la victoire et vous avez également
l'argent éclatant dites-moi rémy 1
qu'ils trouvent les nouveaux que vous
avez à l'avant en écran de 6,5 pouces 6
et du hd plus 1600 par 720 pixels
vous y retrouvez votre caméra de sel est
fini si c'est une caméra de 8 mégapixels
un menton qui est un peu grand une fois
de plus c'est complètement normal dans
cette gamme de prix sur le côté le
bouton de volume bouton pour l'allumer
pour l'éteindre de la recharger sur lies
baisser votre haut parleurs prise jack
le micro tiroirs de cartes sim et je
vous dis moi dans quelques instants ce
qui à l'intérieur la prise en main est
plutôt bien mais ça ce matin qui est
quand même assez lourd j'ai pas le poids
exact mais ça serait pas surprenant
qu'ils fassent un peu plus de 200
grammes côté audio on va retrouver ici
un haut parleur mono haut parleur mono
qui se planquent juste ici c'est un
grand classique on est sur un smartphone
d'entrée de gamme
l'expérience e correct on va pas
s'attendre ici avoir une expérience
immersive ni un sont dingues mais il
fera parfaitement bien à faire pour des
expériences de multimédia de gaming et
si vous le souhaitez pour venir branché
en plus un petit casque ici vous avez
une prise jack
ça c'est un grand hangar une fois de
plus dans l'entrée de gamme et si vous
avez un casque sans fil et bien vous
pouvez venir la paire et en bluetooth
côté performances en trouver 6 1 et
lioger 85 vous avez 4 gigas de ram et 64
go de stockage que vous pouvez venir
augmenter grâce à une carte microsd
parce que oui vous avez dans votre
tiroir qui est situé juste là la
possibilité de mettre double nadeau
symplus carte microsd doublé dan austin
enquête jette évidemment ici on a un
smartphone 4g et nous un smartphone 5 g
ici l'expérience et assumé c'est un
smartphone qui est vraiment axé sur le
gaming vous allez pouvoir faire tourner
plein de jeux du plastoc pas forcément
les jeux les plus performants mais vous
avez vraiment de quoi faire en terme
d'expérience mais je dirais que le gros
point fort de ce smartphone c'est sa
très grosse batterie de 6000
milliampères heures c'est la première
fois que rémy vient d'intégrer une
batterie de 6000 milan perd heures
d'horloge ses smartphones je sais pas si
vous le savez mais je voulais dit plein
de fois sur les smartphones d'entrée et
milieu de gamme
les marques viennent vraiment mettre le
paquet au niveau de la taille de la
batterie au niveau de l'autonomie pour
avoir un smartphone qui ne vous lâche
pas là vous avez une très belle
autonomie de jours pour venir jouer à
des jeux pour du contenu multimédia pour
tout ce que vous voulez c'est un
smartphone qui ne vous lâchera pas et
que vous rechargez en usb c
sasson bloc de 18 watts inclus dans la
boîte et en plus de ça vous bénéficiez
d'une charge l'inversé côté logiciel
vous tombez sur emirates basé sur un
android 10 l'expérience est plutôt bonne
pour devenir clown et des applications
vous avez un espace jeux je vous
laisserai découvrir par vous même et
vous aimez votre tiroir d'application
donc ça ça roule vous y retrouvez un
triplement du photo à l'arrière une
caméra principale de 48 mégapixels un
grand-angle de 8 mégapixels et une
caméra de maquereau de 2 mégapixels plus
un flash led et comme je le disais en
préambule vous avez une caméra de cette
fille de 8 mégapixels
photo prise avec la caméra de 48
mégapixels et écoutez je trouve que le
rendu est quand même plutôt pas mauvais
il ne fait pas beau il pleut on voit
bien les petites gouttes d'un peu
partout ici pour moi le rendu fera très
très bien la faire on passe ensuite s'en
doutera grand-angle il faut savoir qu'on
a aucune stabilisation sur aucun
objectif donc forcément va venir perdre
un peu en précision il ya qu'ultra grand
temps que c'est un peu plus flagrant on
le voit notamment ici en bas au niveau
des feuilles
il vous servira surtout sur des belles
journées ensoleillées pour vous ayez
beaucoup de lumière je ne trouve pas des
formes en ça c'est plutôt bien même si
le rendu n'est pas complètement dingue
il fera la faire mais il faut qu'ils
aient beaucoup lumière et qu'il fasse
beau je suis ou met ensuite en x 2 ça
commence à lycéens on le voit vraiment
au niveau des feuilles on laisse au
capteur principal qui vient cros paix
dans l'image donc rien d'anormal
je suis monté jusqu'au x 5 histoire de
vous montrer un peu on peut aller
jusqu'au 10 mai déjà voyant x 5 salissez
pas exploitables donc le foie de
pourquoi pas au-delà
on oublie on reprend sur la caméra
principale qui viennent nous sortir
quand même pas mal de détails ça c'est
vraiment le traitement logiciel vous le
voyez ici là ça cherche un petit peu à
venir tout exacerbée c'est assez rigolo
pour le coup c'est un peu poussif 1 et
on le voit notamment ici au niveau des
gouttes de pluie elles sont vraiment
vraiment très très très apparentes
après ça fait un petit effet on passe
sur l' ultra grand-angle on a plus de
bruit numérique mais c'est normal on
peut citer pas très très beau
aujourd'hui le même on se rapproche en x
2 et jusqu'en x 5 on oublie caméra
principale l ultra grand-angle
on a un peu plus de mal avec l expo ici
on se rapproche en x 2 x 5 on oublierait
nous a montré la macreuse en moi la
macro ou je ne suis pas très très très
fan sur les smartphones
on doit prendre des photos une licence
de 4 cm c'est pas évident à trouver
quand on a trouvé la bonne distance
pourquoi pas ça lisse fois la bonbonne
soit plus je suis pas très très très fan
de ce genre de photos là vous connaissez
mon avis là dessus
la caméra de celle ci par contre elle
marche vraiment bien elle n'est pas
particulièrement lycée se trouve assez
naturel donc pour de cellfish
franchement ça fera le taf smartphones
trouve plutôt sympa dans l'entrée de
gamme à un tarif deux ne va pas tout
faire à faire le café à manger et à
boire et si vous n'avez pas notamment de
nfc pas certification résistant et à
l'eau et à la poussière
mais dans cette gamme de prix c'est
complètement normal l'expérience malgré
tout est plutôt bonne
un smartphone qui sera agréable pour
faire tourner beaucoup de jeu de dupes
les stars pas les jeux les plus
gourmands bien évidemment mais pour
faire tourner plein de jeux au catalogue
eh bien vous n'aurez pas de problème ici
l'idée c'est d'avoir un smartphone
endurant que vous allez emmener partout
avec vous et qui ne vous lâchera pas mal
donc tout ce que j'avais à vous raconter
aujourd'hui sur ce nouveau smartphone de
rim nuit leur ennemi c'est tenir vous de
me dire vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas or commentaire est ce que vous
trouvez intéressant est ce que vous
connaissiez la marque rémy audio journée
quand même déjà un peu parlé est-ce que
vous la connaissiez est-ce que vous avez
déjà acheté un smartphone de rugby et si
ce n'est pas le cas est ce que vous
pourriez vous laisser tenter et si vous
souhaitez vous laisser tenter
est ce que ça pourrait être par leur
initiative mark et moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire quant à nous je trouve
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer à
parler de teck de l'amour et des vidéos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]